Russia's Security Service says eight
people have been arrested over an
explosion that damaged the courage
bridge to Crimea last week five Russians
and three ukrainians and Armenian
citizens have been detained
all right we can get a little bit more
on that with Muhammad who now joins us
from Moscow Muhammad we just found out
this news in the last few moments what
more can you tell us
well very little has been revealed aside
from that basic line about the number of
people arrested and their nationalities
even those three who are from Ukraine
and the other country Armenia no details
about how many of them are Ukrainian how
many Armenian there are many questions
unanswered about this piece of news we
know from day one that Russia pointed
the finger of accusation at the
Ukrainian intelligence agency saying
they planned this attack and also they
mentioned Russians involved in that we
know that the owner of the bus a young
man from an area very close Russian area
very close to the bridge he said he's
innocent he doesn't know what happened
because it's his uncle who was the
driver of that truck and who used to use
it in delivery
long distance it seems and the the uncle
died in that blast with any secrets that
he might have so people are waiting for
more answers about this more details
sales we don't know where these people
came from exactly were they living in
Russia or but did they come straight
from Ukraine the the the the the the the
trip of that truck began in Bulgaria and
it crossed Armenia and Georgia and the
Russian territory before it reached uh
uh Crimea so there is a there is a lot
of questions unanswered as I said in
this and probably more details will come
in the next hours or so if the FSB wants
to reveal more about this situation yeah
absolutely okay we'll keep checking in
with you Muhammad Val reporting live
from Moscow thank you very much